it's not the biggest town in the state
and it's not the smallest it's an
average town and people here are pretty
much like people anywhere
for instance take Rodney he's courteous
and he's friendly I am he's popular too
hello Rodney hire
he's good at sports
he's law-abiding
and is helpful
and Rodney smart enough to get a
physical checkup once a year
including a chest x-ray
gee doctor that what I look like hmm
what's the matter seems to be a spot
here some spot where in me here in your
love but we can't tell whether it means
anything just from this x-ray would have
to make some other ten that says in
tuberculin test tuberculin test and
we'll get another x-ray another x-ray
what's it all about am I think
well Rodney the laboratory tests and
this new x-rays show that you have
active TB tuberculosis tuberculosis me
you must be wrong doc I never felt
better in my life
early TB doesn't have to have symptoms
you haven't even know you say you never
felt better
what's it mean am i a goner I'm too
young to die people my age don't get TV
it must be something else maybe it's
just a touch of asthma don't you think
it has my doubts go down son people any
age can get tuberculosis because you've
had regular physical checkup we found
your TV before it's had a chance to get
really bad early tuberculosis like yours
can be cure sure it takes a little time
see what is TB anyway well it's a
disease caused by the tubercle bacillus
a jerk these germs get into the air
around us they can stay alive in the air
all right but they'd rather be in a
place where it's warm and moist and dark
like your lungs where they can multiply
and grow and get plenty of food who me
yes you you're their food if the germs
get into your lungs and your body
doesn't fight back fast enough and you
get active TV and you can spread germs
how about that well who spread it to me
how'd I get it well there's no knowing
exactly maybe you have been around
people who had TV and didn't know it
they're spitting sneezing and coughing
can load the air with TB germs gee I
always thought TB was something you
found only in places like slums sure in
any crowded place disease can spread
faster to more people and these people
may not be able to get enough good food
rest and medical check-ups but Rodney
germs don't know one person from another
rich or poor little or big anyone can
get needy
I guess coughing sneezing or spitting is
bad anywhere it sure is but everyone has
the same good chance to be cure if TV is
found early as early as yours okay how
do we start curing it
what sort of medicine do I take the best
medicine for you is plenty of rest now
start today afternoon naps know the best
place to rest is in a tuberculosis
Hospital Hospital but I can't go way off
somewhere I've never even been out of
the state
I'd rather rest at home besides I don't
want to go
so Rodney entered the hospital but it
wasn't up in the mountains and it wasn't
off in a desert
this where I'm gonna stay dot that's
right right here near home well this
isn't so bad
of course not rod but going to get you
well is good food and rest
mostly rest
you don't have to go to a special
climate we can cure TB in any climate
because you can get plenty of rest and
the proper food in any tuberculosis
Hospital wherever it is see my folks can
come here to see me and and my girl
hey you sure they don't have it all if
that's we've made show your folks are ok
rod and we'll keep further check on them
to make sure they stay that way that's
another reason for coming here rod it
protects your family and friend
say doc what do I do to keep in shape
around here I can take a good workout
once in a while can i son you're sick
look if you had a broken foot do you
think it would be smart to kick a
football with it if your back was
praying would you mow the lawn it's the
same with your thighs you want to keep
them as quiet as possible so they'll
heal do you know that just running takes
fifty breaths a minute even walking
takes 25
you stay in bed and you'll be using your
lungs as little as possible sometimes
when a lung can't heal even with
complete bed rest an operation can
collapse it so it doesn't have to do any
work at all the other lung does all the
breathing necessary until the diseased
lungs heal and can go back to work again
but we're not going to try that now you
can see why we want you here instead of
at home home just isn't designed for the
kind of
this hospital is and if you should need
drugs or surgery the hospital doctors
and nurses are right here to give them
to you
Rodney caught on the thing that would
cure him now was not activity but rest
the medicine was rest good food and
plenty of rest it didn't happen
overnight but the rest began to do its
job gradually his lung began to heal to
get well he could use it more and more
until finally one day
hey back I arrived
hyah
Kieran was lucky lucky no Rodney was
smart smart enough to have a medical
check-up and an x-ray once a year